BAM we're only took me a few minutes I'm
a few minutes late not too bad not too
bad just I was like like I don't know
ten minutes away from going alive and I
was like oh my god like I don't have any
coffee I was like man I didn't make some
coffee need to make something for myself
to drink 1 i'm doing this Q&A session
but anyway so so what's up guys how's
the how's everything going how's absent
happening you guys have a good fourth of
July I had a good fourth of July I was
working on the Silver Surfer video and
initially I was talking about going out
but you know it's it's insane outside if
I guess I the fourth is a lie here in
town cuz i live on campus and you have a
bunch of irresponsible college kids who
are getting all crazy drunk and so on
and so forth and driving around this one
thing you're going to be you know
getting intoxicated hanging out with
friends but it's another if you're going
to be driving around and so on it's
think I kind of crazy so i figured i'm
just going to stay inside play some
destiny work on the Silver Surfer video
and call it a night and I did and it was
nice although I did go to kroger to get
some burritos at one point so it was a
good call but um anyway oh my goodness
so i got i have a few youtube celeb you
just boot your new pc a thousand-dollar
build wow what you put in it like i'm
kind of curious what you put in your
system um yeah my I'd have switched
everything around is all I did with my
apartment like before I was facing
facing that way but now I'm the desk
facing the other way so this is the back
of my apartment so love you guys wanted
like an apartment tour like show us your
setup like that's my setup I live in
this little studio apartment but I'm
saving up money to buy a house so that's
why I live in a studio I mean the
apartment I had before was like this
great big apartment you know that had
like a fireplace and all I kind of stuff
and it was unnecessary I didn't need all
that stuff so I just got rid of it but
um
but yeah so I guess I didn't get rid of
it I guess I moved out of it so I didn't
like burn down the building I got rid of
the entire apartment complex um I'm glad
you guys love the Silver Surfer video I
put a lot of work into that and as I was
getting to the end of it and i was i was
looking at it I was like dude people are
going to go nuts over the Silver Surfer
video like people are gonna dig this and
and I'm glad you guys enjoyed it I'm
glad you guys really liked it so um how
much magic magic happens on that bed
enough enough magic happens on that bed
that I don't have to worry about too
many things so um can i play the guitar
yes I can play guitar um let's see is
you to buy main income yeah I make I
make you'd like the videos I make for
you guys for a living it so can i play
for you no i'm not gonna play for you
guys do you play guitar in your videos
no i don't i usually like go on a
youtube i find a video that i like and i
sort of message to the youtuber hey do
you care if i use your content usually
there's like no i don't care but
sometimes you're just like no you can't
use my content i'm like okay well then
fine with your 5000 subscribers like I
just won't give you any you know any
like you know what do they call that
publicity and will be like hey go check
this guy's channel out like i'll let you
stay there and make your videos and
whatever so I'll speaking of which so um
if you look down in the description for
those of you guys who have just joined
everything you'll find strange and
studios and strange man studios is the
is a YouTube channel that I found on the
weekly pool and again as you guys know
where for those of you guys who were new
here during comics in coffee I take I
take a you tube channel that I found on
the weekly pool net and I use that as a
platform basically saying like here is a
channel you guys should check out and
you know this channel I think it's
pretty solid I mean you know a lot of
these channels are up-and-coming my goal
is to find channels that have less than
500 subscribers and give them a shout
out and you know as long as they're
producing good content and as long as
they have a decent back catalogue of me
I don't expect you to have a hundred
videos we've got 10 or 15 videos or
something like that or you know seven
eight or nine or whatever you know give
you a shout out as long as you're you're
putting your all into
your videos as long as you're trying to
make good content again these are
usually comic book videos periodically
I'll branched out and I'll do something
entirely different people who are you
know doing unboxings or something like
that you know branch out and say hey you
know check those guys at but for right
now they're usually just uh just coming
book videos so but yeah that's that's
that's down the description so make sure
you guys take a look at that channel say
Rob sent me here and it'll be like yay
let's see um xbox one or ps4 I actually
have both but i prefer the ps4 to be
honest I've got destiny on the ps4 i
have arkham knight on the xbox one and
the reason why I did that is because my
thought was okay let's let's experiment
like let's get a really good game that I
can play on multi player on the on the
ps4 to see how their network holds up
and because xbox one or xbox already
establish is having a really really good
multiplayer system may establish that
with Halo and Call of Duty and
Battlefield and so I was like let's
let's check out you know the xbox on how
it performs for the game like Arkham
Knight and in truth there's a noticeable
difference like you can notice egg
Arkham Knight on like the differs in
terms of how it looks on the xbox one
like like this does not look like an
Xbox one game this looks like an xbox
360 game which kind of sucks but you
know it's whatever what is the poster in
the background the poster over there the
poster over there is John Lennon that is
a picture of him and it has the lyrics
from imagine so one of the coolest songs
he ever made do I like anime yes I love
dragon ball z that is the extent of my
anime experience that's about as far as
it goes I never really got into anime
aside from that I've watched a little
bit of stuff like ronin warriors and I
couldn't get the Sailor Moon it seemed
like a show geared more towards girls
but um you know I never really could get
into that into that whole thing um let's
see oh my god the questions are rolling
in am I excited for ant-man yes I am
very excited for ant-man I don't think a
lot of people are I think a lot of
people are just kind of like man ant-man
but I think ant-man is going to be the
sleeper I think ant-man is going to roll
into the theaters no one's going to
think anything of it and it's just going
to blow up and people are going to be
like
my god this movie is amazing or they
could go into the theaters and people
are just like man this movie sucks we
really have no idea until it comes out
having said that we have like a week and
a half and so I'm really excited like
I'm really digging it um have I ever
consider doing a spawn explain yes I've
thought about explaining this one
character and I probably will at some
point it's just not right now the
favorite Walking Dead character
definitely Rick unless you if you're
talking about the TV show it's
definitely Daryl what if you're talking
about the comics I love Rick I love Rick
in the comics because he's so different
from the TV show like in the comics he's
hopeful like like when they get to the
community like he's really hopeful he
wants things to be better but you know
they're they're not you know things are
going to be are gonna be really really
well they get really bad in the
community so um yeah I get it gets
really rough so um let's see yeah ma I
got good reviews from the early
screenings I saw that I mean I know
pretty much all the spoilers for the
ant-man movie I just I still want to go
see it you know because I'm really
digging you know where it's gonna go and
I'm really thinking that it's gonna be
it's gonna fit in really really well but
you know it's yeah I won't ruin anything
else to anything else for you guys but
I'm pretty sight for it so um let's see
have I seen hermit terminator genisys
yes and I um I was talking a bit me the
other day and Benny I asked him you know
what was going on he was like I want to
go see terminator genisys and I was like
what do you think about that and he was
like I it was okay and I was like yeah
it wasn't that good it wasn't it was a
very good at all my 10 meter Genesis was
just like it's it seemed like what they
tried to do was reboot the tornado
franchise and did a terrible job at it
because what what made the original see
this is the problem that Hollywood has
they don't understand what made movies
really really good originally I love you
rob oh my god oh thank you i guess it's
kind of creepy but aren't they don't
understand what made movies really good
originally
movies i terminated were considered so
solid because they were something so
brand-new I mean it was such a cool
concept the idea of it was cool but once
people got into the mythology the
honeymoon period was gone and the
interest wore off and so now you've got
so many movies out there about dystopian
societies that there's there you haven't
been able to make a movie or make a
version of the Terminator that inspires
people that makes people interested that
keep people coming back in the truth I
don't know that they can I mean I don't
know if you can make a terminator movie
that would be solid you know going
forward I mean I don't know but anyway
um offense oh no I'm doing good how are
you doing why do you change your channel
from Marvel explain a comet's explain
because I gives me the opportunity to
branch out into other stuff like like
one of the things that we're thinking
about is taking like the way we've been
doing videos recently and doing kingdom
come that way like talking about DC's
kingdom come or the dark knight returns
you know Frank Miller's run of that man
just different things like that I'm not
really sure yet but it's it's really
difficult to to do this kind of thing
with DC stories because DC stories are
usually really really really really long
I mean like character arcs are huge I
mean Geoff Johns character arc for the
Green Lantern series is just massive in
scope it consists of like six different
series it was it's nuts how big it is
and so um you know it's really difficult
to do that with big with with DC would
be Bigfoot's in comics it's really
difficult to do that with DC but I still
want to give it a shot you know I still
want to try that and see if and see if I
can pull that off so did you watch
dragon ball super no i haven't actually
and i need to i really really really
really need to and i will i think i'm
gonna watch that tonight because right
now i pardon me I had to burp I have the
script finished 44 Punisher the end like
Punisher the last man on earth which
that comes out tomorrow which we're
going to talk about that here in a
minute but but yeah I have the script
finish for that and and so I think I
might you know record the audio and then
watch dragon ball super and then go
ahead and work on the video afterwards
but here's the thing okay so so as you
guys know like you guys really really
seemed to enjoy the new
the new Christian Malecki what's up you
asked me to notice you I have noticed
you um you guys like you guys have
really really been psyched about the new
way we're doing videos which are fun
like I love doing those videos is so
cool finding music to go with the videos
challenging but they're really fun to do
and you know I I knew it was gonna
happen eventually but some of you guys
on the comments were like Rob are you
okay because you've been doing like some
really really like depressing and
dystopian stories or you can with like a
phase or something like that like I'm
fine it's just for me I think that some
of those stories are some of the best
written stories because they give us a
version of the character that we never
see like we never get to see the only
exception to that is Garth Ennis 'as
punisher max which punish the end draws
a huge amount of inspiration for putters
for max I mean it was the reason like
Punisher max was the reason why we got
you know Punisher the end I cannot like
like what is it like four months after
the series after Punisher max first
started in 2004 and so it was you know
they were they really heavily influence
one another but um you know it's I'd
from that you know a lot of them just
give us versus that we don't get to see
now some of the end stories are kind of
crappy like I wasn't a huge fan of the
x-men wasn't a huge fan of the Fantastic
Four you know some of those things I
didn't think we're that grade but
nonetheless you know it was it was a
really cool really cool concept so um
what do I think about all new all
different marvel I think it's a good
call um you know I I think that the
problem with with Marvel and their
current run at least what they have
right now is if if you guys are new and
this is what reasons why my channel and
Benny's channel or South channel have
been so successful is because if you're
new you have no idea where to start if
it's if it's currently to another 15 and
you were born in the year 2000 and you
say okay I want to start reading expired
a man because you know that spider-man
is going to be part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and you want to know
what all the hype is the problem is you
just don't know where read I mean you
don't know where to go and people to
like okay you know what what can I read
to start off with spider-man and it's
like okay well I mean you can go all the
way back like 50 years you know and
start from there and people are like oh
no i don't
do that it's like well I mean here's
like like 12 story arcs that you should
read I mean that's the problem that's
why DC has it right when DC does reboots
DC says okay we're rebooting the entire
continuity this is year one so if you're
new to the comics start with this year
it's all you need nothing beforehand
mattered unless you're Batman of the
Green Lantern that's why those things
are so cool and I think that's why you
know Marvel really needed to consider
doing that Marvel and truth really
needed to look at the idea of doing a
reboot the problem here is if it
happened if we confuse a lot of fans
from the movies and what confuse it
would really piss off a lot of fans in
the comics and so you know while I think
it would have been a good idea it also
probably would not have been a good idea
so but nonetheless you know why your
spine a woman pregnant we don't know yet
that kind of catch them in early now
once it comes out post secret words I'm
sure we'll find out but at the moment
right now we don't know Rob rang call
the in the model Cinematic Universe
films from best to worse that would take
a little while but off the top of my
head i mean i'd say Iron Man's the best
one so far but I think a lot of people
will say iron man because that's a movie
that started at all and so it has like a
special place and in the fans of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe after iron man
it's kind of a toss-up i mean i'd say
maybe like like The Incredible Hulk you
know but there's also like guardians of
the galaxy well guard is the galaxy's
definitely better than the incredible
hulk so I say Otis of the galaxy number
two The Incredible Hulk you know maybe
34 something like that it's really kind
of tough to do because a lot of the
movies have really cool elements but a
lot of the movies are kind of dumb to
like Avengers was fun to watch but
Avengers had no character development
but it didn't really need to because all
the character development have been done
in their films and so you know we didn't
need to see them like you know hey I'm
meeting you for the first time it didn't
need to happen in that movie you know so
nonetheless you know I think that that
it's tough to do you know it really
depends on your preference of the kind
of movies you like so um Rob do you sing
I used to when I was in high school I
was an all-state but between between
cigarettes and just not not singing I
pretty much destroyed my singing voice
so most look forward to title after
secret wars the the adventures i think
the cover that was released with that
was done by alex ross like that's what
i'm looking forward to that looks solid
um but again you know i'm looking
forward to Miles Morales Miles Morales
is publication I'm looking forward to
see what they do I'm miniature to see
what they do with Peter Parker you know
I'm kind of curious to see where that
goes I mean one of the things we talked
about during the podcast was that it
felt like renew your vows was really
more of a hommage renew your vows was
like as far as Marvel goes regarding DC
like spider-man fan's you know DC I
convergence where they said here's all
these old stories coming back that you
guys love so much and fans are like okay
cool you know but with with Marvel you
know a lot of fans spider-man fans
especially and even just like no I'm
never going to quit vaping babying is
amazing but um my I get I guess you know
with with spider-man fan's they looked
at one more day and they said God you
know this this story sucks you know one
more day is awful what do you see good
warriors number four by the way this
week will probably be that on Wednesday
so um but a lot of people were just like
like man one more day with garbage it
was awful it sucked i mean yeah the
story was really really cool written it
was really you know interesting but
spider-man would not sell his soul to
the devil that's just never going to
happen and that's the most ridiculous
thing I've ever heard of and then even
michael Straczynski was like yeah that's
that's a stupid idea but hey i had to
write something so you know i wrote that
and then I quit like I was talking to
Sal and sounds like yeah dude after one
more day Straczynski like quit marvel
that was like man I don't blame him but
um nonetheless you know I think a lot of
fans looked at one more day hated it and
so marble said okay you know here is
here spider-man renew your vows all of
you guys that hated one more day all of
you that thought one more day was an
absolute atrocity you know here is renew
your vows here's the spider-man that
stayed with Mary Jane Watson and so they
were like cool and that's just kind of a
tip of the hat ahamed saying here's the
story that you wanted here's the future
that you wanted for that character but
that's not mainstream or 6 16 Peter
Parker and so I'm curious to see you
know what they're going to do with Peter
Parker going forward either way I want
to read it you know I'm
at the very least I'm just kind of kind
of curious yes we'll finish Age of
Apocalypse this week um how to destroy
the beyonders we don't know we have no
idea how that happened yet I thought we
were going to get an explanation I
thought I thought dr. strange is going
to be like okay guys like here's
everything that happened and then he's
just like here is a hint of what
happened and that was it and I was
pissed I was like come on hickman like
come on dude but Hickman's really well
known for that Hickman is really well
known for saying hey guys like here's
all the information that you want not
really do suck to wait am I excited for
fallout 4 hell yeah I am who's not
excited for fallout 4 that's my question
like fallout 4 looks amazing like I mean
I am really excited for that I mean the
interactivity the look of the game you
know my concern is is it going to feel
like a next-gen game is it gonna feel
like a game that's that's totally new is
it going to feel like a game that that
looks you know brand new or is it going
to feel like a reskinned fallout 3
bethesda does not have a history of
making crappy games so regardless of how
the game looks its kind of play amazing
and so I'm gonna check it out no matter
what happens rob was your favorite model
TV series definitely well during devil
was cool wall at last so the question is
this daredevil how to have a lot of like
rewatch value i don't think so i think
daredevil was good to like watch once i
really haven't had a reason to go back
and watch it again but i would say
agents of shield is probably my favorite
one at the moment just because of how it
falls indirectly and ties in directly
with the Marvel Cinematic Universe
nefler I guess your devil doesn't do
that daredevil just kind of is out there
and and and it's just you know and
that's it so we know it ties in it's
just it seems like levels saying yeah so
the same universe and that's it as
opposed to Marvel saying yes it's in the
same universe and here's how it's in the
same universe like it just seems so just
kind of tossed in there and so isolated
but you know I don't know I mean at the
end of the day you know it really kind
of depends so it'll feel next-gen on PC
yeah i'll be playing it on pc i mean
i've got a tight next like i'll be
playing it on pc i'm pretty psyched so
check twitter you tweeted me okay well
let's let's see what you tweeted me on
twitter
I don't see anything on here why did you
tweet me what did u sin we're doing what
no oh my god you guys get Benny all
riled up he has to get Benny stirred up
which one of you did it that's what I
want to know that's always my question
whenever I see something popping off I'm
like oh my god which one of you guys
started out Vinny again hey Rob since
that the Sun is doing this doing this
fight who do you think would win
superman vs darth maul or spiderman vs
darth maul there we go um hmm spiderman
vs darth maul I'd sleep Howie spider-man
he would just use his webbing to yank
the lightsaber out of Darth Maul's hand
but north wall has a force to sew em
alone that was going to take some
thought off the top of my head I'd say
it was it's probably probably darts mole
of top my head I'd say Darth Maul while
we take it but um when I could ever
consider becoming a comic book writer
probably not I don't think I'd ever want
to become a color book writer it doesn't
really interest me too much you mean the
idea of writing comics I think you'd
just be too stressful like sitting
around and trying to think of something
new would drive me up the wall you looks
like the question of would you rather be
a dance music producer or a DJ I rather
be a DJ any day of the week I'd rather
just like go around in nightclubs and
just play music like it would be awesome
I don't want to make this stuff I just
want to enjoy it so um let's see the
fanbase explain my family's has had a
couple names over the years when I can't
think of one like okay you guys think of
one like I thought of Marfa lights I've
thought of different things the comic
nation you know but I'm not really sure
my colleague nation like I like the
combination but I'm not sure you know
let me know am I excited for civil war
yes I am very excited for civil war like
I am super excited for civil war I think
the Civil War is let's see here's a
reason
the question becomes what's more we're
gonna do with civil war a civil war
going to be you know jason jason
matthews called me fatty who know
someone called me fat what do i do i
think that that civil war is in the most
automatic universe as far as i
understand it i think that i think it's
supposed to be something based around
what Honda and the debate as to whether
or not to like break in there and if
that's the plot of civil war though
they're debating whether or not they
should invade Wakanda that's a really
flimsy plot like that that's this that's
a really flimsy plot and so I'm that
would be really disappointing but you
know either way you know I would I
definitely go check it out like I'm
gonna go see it you know because I
couldn't I mean why wouldn't I who in
what universe would anyone believe that
me or venir asal would not go see
Captain America 3 civil war so the Rob
core that is a cool idea the Rob core
the watch the Watchers there we go the
Watchers that is a good call you guys
are the Watchers what a good call what a
good call um why did I create this
channel I made this channel because one
I love comics and two because I thought
to be cool for people who are fans of
comic books your fans limo cinematic
universe to have a place to go where
they can learn all the information they
want to learn about County books and
what in the world okay so like I sell
because i was talking them about the new
the Superman arc we're on the Superman
loses his powers and I was like is this
work over here and they're like nope
sounds like I don't think that arch
gonna end for a long time and I was like
well that's sucks so that blows so
anyway um
establish that you guys are the chat
know you guys are the chat in in the
weekly poll like the weekly poll podcast
you guys are the chat like you guys are
not the chat and my and on my channel
like you guys who were fans of my
Chandler are different you guys were a
different group of people you're totally
totally something else um let's see call
the sow sounds actually recording I hit
him up earlier then I was like hey man
would you be interested in joining me on
an episode of the weekly or of the
weekly pool of how much the coffee needs
like I'm actually gonna be recording so
I was like well that sucks so um let's
see who is my favorite superhero my
all-time favorite superhero is Robert
riddles the century because I love his
original story but aside from that I
mean I don't know i mean the problem
with centuries you got crappy after his
original story so that might open a fan
or yes and what I'm actually thinking
about doing and I probably going to call
a call or go over there tomorrow because
I live right around the corner I might
go to the post office and see like how
long it takes or what I have to do in
order to open a p.o box because I think
it'd be really cool if I had a p.o box
and you guys could send me stuff the
problem is I think it Phillips super
fast and I'd have so much stuff I
wouldn't know what to do with it all so
nonetheless you know I think it'd be
nothing to be a cool concept but I
wouldn't mind getting like a bulletin
board or something like that and and
just like like pinning like pictures and
stuff like that on there because I think
it'd be really fun so let's see do you I
think Drax the destroyer will be more
powerful and Guardians the galaxy two
after his dip in the yellow celestial
bath the yellow celestial bath home has
he dipped in that I remember that unless
it was a scene that I missed from
guardians of the galaxy one maybe I
forgot but I don't know Shazam is the
best Oh Shazam is I mean he's a he's a
good character I mean he's really one of
the only people that can match the
strength of Superman so he's solid but
you know I don't know emmaus he was
never really for me so
what am I vaping what am I vaping on I
am currently vaping on uh pinup vapors
this was called Marilyn oh and I'm
interested I want to show you guys
something to hold on a second let me run
my cabinet me grab it I'll be right back
oh my goodness okay so for all you I'll
you vaping fans out there all you vapor
fans here in the as part of the are you
vaping Watchers there we go i order some
new Jesus and I got some juices from the
vapor chef and the vapor chef let's see
is a solid juice maker like they're
they're really really good all right I
got Hobbes blood which is an amazing
juice it's like coconut and fruity
flavors and it tastes oh my god it
tastes so good that's how be the best
juice they have the second one I got is
Beeblebrox which is named after his
ephod people Brock's from the oh god
what is it called hitchhiker's guide to
the galaxy he was played by I'll
remember the actors name anymore but
anyway this is a tobacco flavor and its
really really good so um the next one is
deep thought and deep thought is a
tobacco flavor with some vanilla so I'm
really really really psyched for that
the next one is carries berries which is
like a really fruity flavor that tastes
like really really good and the last one
is one of my favorite ones this is
unicorn poop this is yet another fruity
flavor like I think the fruity flavor
juices taste the best but you got to
balance it out you know with stuff like
um like tobacco flavors and different
things like that so um so let's see oh
my god jason matthew guesses gets to
join a long list of people who have had
the banhammer thrust upon them and
spectacular fashion and shall henceforth
never see this channel again um played
by mos def do most def is so solid dude
I love using my most def like he makes
it like him and Talib Kweli black star
like they're they make such good music
yeah unicorn poop is really really good
so um you sent me a Twitter you sent me
a whole twitter I gave you the Twitter's
would you like a Twitter's i have three
Twitter's for you if you had to make a
Silver Surfer trilogy that ends with a
requiem or annihilation what would the
first to be I have no clue that is a
difficult question that is a difficult
question oh yeah the banhammer just
dropped hard like I mean the only I
don't know I don't even ask that much
the only thing I asked for is that
you're courteous to the people in the
chat and then you conduct yourself like
a grown-up and if you can't do that then
you get the banhammer with extreme
prejudice and I regret nothing let's see
well I make more videos on secret wars
yes see here's the problem here so
here's the thing guys The Secret Wars
doesn't we get get released like weekly
or monthly what was supposed to but they
actually I'm having a push ticket worse
number four back I've been doing the
videos as the comics have come out and
so you know what secret for secret wars
number four coming out of course we'll
talk about that and then with the other
sick of wars you know as those are
release we'll talk about those to you
and the reason for that is because one
secret wars ends then we'll be able to
will have all the secret war stories
finished and then we'll be able to go
through and do x x 92 will be able to
you use our future past all that stuff
and say your secret wars already if you
want to check it out so and we'll be
able to just kind of go from there so
why do I vape I've a because well i
started vaping to get off cigarettes but
I think now because it's just an
enjoyable hobby I mean it's a nice hobby
to have to to break away from using
regular cigarettes and using this I've
been vaping for like two years roughly
so a friend of my dad got me started on
it my original setup believe it or not I
don't know if I still have it I don't
think I do now my wait a minute I have
my original original tank or an
old-school tank anyway but this is the
aspire Nautilus mini and actually i got
that after i got that like a year or two
year and a half ago something like that
a year ago so unless you know i'm a
friend of mine dan got me on about my
original setting original setup for
vaping was the
evo twist with a pro tank I protank mini
and from there I just branched out and
stuff and now i'm using a let's see what
is this the atlantis aspire atlantis
version 2 and the sigelei 100 watt plus
for all you guys who were curious so the
I thought Kingdom Come was a really good
story I really enjoyed it I thought it
was pretty solid so Rob do you go back
to the chat log and answer questions I
try to answer them as they come in but
the problem is there's so many questions
that come in I can't answer them all so
usually people will just kind of repeat
their questions or something like that
so whosoever holds the ban hammer if he
be worthy shall possess a power Rob
whosoever conducts themself like a child
in my Chad if they be unworthy shall get
banned by the ban hammer there we go um
I use a nautilus mini now yeah the
aspire Nautilus mini is really good but
here's the kicker I mean it's one of
those things where once you branch out
like if you get an aspire atlantis or
you get a let's see a ought to lyst like
an arrow tank or something like that
like once once you once you branch out
into that you're never going to go back
to the to the Nautilus many because it's
just so awesome because with ease you
get so much more vapor and you get so
much more flavor and you just never go
back to it so I'm not going to play my
guitar I'm not going to play my guitar
moon night i'm sorry i'm not gonna play
the guitar for you i know you wish i
would but i'm not going to play the
guitar so let's see what comic book
character needs their own saturday
morning store news around saturday
morning cartoon what kind of a character
needs arose saturday morning cartoon the
punisher no that would be the most adult
oriented saturday morning cartoon ever
could you imagine that the punisher
cartoon show like kids are getting their
cereal and the Punishers like
gratuitously murdering people blowing
their heads off and stuff like that you
know um no I'm are birds heads are
falling off i get i get maybe it's just
me maybe it's just like the ad D the
kick
sin but like I'll have a thought and
i'll be like speaking my thought and
it'll be like random thought and it'll
just come out that's the problem with
having a DD is I think I've had it
somebody summed it up on reddit really
really well somebody said the problem
with a DD is you like like you're you're
going through a room going through you
know performing a task or something like
that like I need to do this thing and
you're working on that thing and all the
sudden you're like shining object and
you immediately like you capture the
attention of that shiny object you know
but the really cool thing is that those
who are a TD are able to multitask
better than those who aren't so i think
i think so and even though that's not
true it makes me feel better to believe
it's true so I don't mind it now let's
see Jon Garland Bucky will replace OE
talk about a dog charlyn okay um by the
way Jon Garland I'm think you were civil
your email or send me your address um if
you did I missed it so you send it to me
again because I think it was you that
won the contests before I don't member
getting anything from you so if that was
you let me know and if it wasn't you
then please don't lie and say it was she
what's going on Stewart stark just
chillin drinking some coffee and talking
to you fine people so I let's see Marvel
or detective comics who's better well
it's really not a matter of better so
much as it is different but the type of
comics are really cool because well
because it's Batman's history I mean
detective comics or literally Batman's
history in comic book form and you
detective comics been around forever so
um you know I like um I mean you can't
really compare like detective comics to
marvel you can't really say like here's
like one aspect of DC how does it
compare to like the whole of Marvel
Comics I mean you can't really do that
you could say like detective comics
versus like Iron Man comics or something
like that but Thomas Sharpe it's all
good like I mean we've we've got you
know another 20 minutes or so before we
bounce off of here so Rob how do you
take your coffee well I used to take my
coffee with 3 with a 2 equal and to
cream but now I'll just take mine with
like like two equal so I don't want to
use creamer anymore
who would win bat-mite or doop doop
hands down I mean I'll even know why
asking question you know like when you
know who ever doubted the power of dupe
let's let's see if salv still recording
you're still recording cinema message if
Sal's not too busy we might be able to
hit him up and be like hey man join me
for like the last 20 minutes of my show
but I think it still recording right now
so um oh okay I thought you're talking
about like like yeah I notice I notice
an abbreviation for for DC but I think
you're talking about like like detective
comics Batman's history then I was a you
can't compare like Batman single run of
comics um okay well if you guys know
about marvel vs DC I had a video once
called marvel vs DC which as far as you
guys are concerned doesn't exist anymore
but um it was you can't really compare
the truth because I used to be the
biggest fan of Marvel I was like Marvel
only Marvel's the best one and then as
time progressed I was like you can't
really compare the two like I mean they
have they both have really cool aspects
of it I mean Batman Superman or classic
characters they're timeless like Batman
is Superman are timeless like those
characters will never get old from now
to a hundred years from now assuming
that we haven't wiped ourselves off the
map and destroyed all forms of
information you know the idea of
Superman and Batman will still exist and
people will say oh my god Batman yeah I
remember that guy like he was solid and
people will still be reading Batman
comics you know when a hundred years
most likely maybe not in comics but you
know in some form of media Batman will
still exists in the same with Superman
you know deezer I'm sorry Marla has
spider-man marvel has Captain America I
mean Marvel has great character so each
one has their own you know each one has
their own solid solid thing John Carlin
I just got your email i appreciated but
um each one has their own you know
variation of what's going on so you know
really hang a pair of you to appear each
one because they they're respectful in
their own rights so having said that
Marvel is a whole lot better than DC
let's see on Mei versus Rob on me like I
let me tell you something if I were to
try to fight on made she'd beat the hell
out of me I have no doubt because she
used to be a secret agent she was a spy
back in the day according to Sony anyway
so spider-man death in the fam ok well
there's there's death of the family and
there's death in the family death in the
family with Jason Todd dying or
supposedly dying death of the family was
when the Joker made his return um we
talked about nothing the family during
our video about Jason Todd that was a
huge moment in the history of DC Comics
and comic books in general I mean you
know to have a sidekick murdered so
brutally it was it was one thing to have
a sidekick died I mean that wasn't
unheard of to have a sidekick die or
have a major superhero died or something
like that I mean it wasn't wasn't the
most unheard-of thing you could imagine
you know I mean even even at that point
in time you know in you know in the 80s
nothing is when that happened people
were ready they were like okay you know
let's let's see you know some darker
stuff but um you know I think that that
I think it wasn't i think it was an 80s
84 or something like that 85 island off
the top of my head but um but no i mean
you know it was it was still pretty
brutal I mean the Joker beat him to
death and then blew him up I mean that
was just that was insane it was a great
story i loved it i mean i thought it was
an incredible i think was a little weird
that like it ended up in pakistan and
you know Jason Todd trying to find his
real mom and so on was kind of strange
you know but nonetheless the story in
and of itself is it's pretty solid so
what do I think about Marvel wanted
Beyonce in the MCU I really hope not I
really hope they're not trying to get
Beyonce in the MCU um beyoncé beyoncé
needs to stick to singing I mean you
know 1986 there we go so he also needs
to stick to singing you know she's a
really good singer she has amazing music
and I think she's best sticking to that
so how much wood would a woodchuck chuck
if if it would chuck was Batman how much
wood would a woodchuck chuck if a
woodchuck was bad man he'd check a lot
of would he
he chuck a lot of women so um the Joker
was just misunderstood how do people get
to be on a weekly poll um we're sorting
that out but I'm not going to give you
guys any answers on that right now let's
see Miles Morales think will be the best
huh second let's scroll back up let's
see well I lost a question now oh well
anyway do I play costs of Champions no I
do not play contest of Champions I never
played that before so um let's see have
I beaten Arkham Knight yet yes I be
talking right Rob explains Destiny's
Child yeah didn't Beyonce saying it's on
again an amazing spider-man 2 I don't
know but it wouldn't surprise me like it
would not surprise me at all oh that was
Alicia Keys okay cool oh god Alesha
Keith Moon Man she is she's very
talented like she has a beautiful voice
I like pianos yeah she is she's
unbelievable when it comes to making
music one of the best musicians of our
time so let's say your favorite
underrated DC and Marvel character well
again I'm not nearly as knowledgeable
about about DC as I'm about Marvel but i
would say probably the most underrated
Marvel characters or at the very least
under used as a Silver Surfer like he's
not used enough or at least his solo
series I suppose series aren't properly
or enough you know people just don't
really look at him as as a solid
character they just kind of say well you
know we know who Silver Surfer is you
know but let's see Rob you ever listen
to Kevin Smith's podcast like fat man on
Batman I've heard of that I got heard of
his podcast I listened to him a few
times but usually I'm so busy these days
I don't have time to listen other
people's podcasts on making videos i'm
working on my own so let's see are you
exited 40 excited for guardians to
what's your thoughts I mean we're world
too
to really think too much about going
into the galaxy two but I think we're
going to see Adam warlock and guardians
of the galaxy two so I'm psyched about
it you know regardless I mean I'm
looking forward to it so I should do
what we're hoping Morgan Freeman's voice
I wish I could but I don't I can't I
don't have Morgan Freeman's voice so
let's see quasars Marvel's most
undervalued character of when I say
undervalued I mean a character that
people should care about more but don't
nobody should care about quasar-like
boys are sucks always I think it does
anyway so let's see I am Groot well
that's awesome i'm new to marvel so what
would you say top 10 must read stories
top sending stories and marvel comics
well the current Secret Wars offense
number one because this story isn't
incredible following that is time runs
out which leads up to the Secret Wars so
that's really a must read after that
Civil War number three easily before
that I'd say probably Infinity Gauntlet
and then age of apocalypse and then
probably fatal attractions if you love
the x-men let's see there's also some
really old old stories to that are
pretty solid I'll be the original Secret
Wars you original contest of Champions
you could read inferno I mean there's
there's some there's some solid stories
out there will the DC Cinematic Universe
succeed of course it will because DC I
think it's found their niche I think DC
has found their niche in the form of TV
shows and cartoon movies and and they're
solid I think the problem is a lot of
people kind of snuff at that they say
all these e cartoon movies whatever you
can have that we're making regular
movies such that's stupid so the
cinnamon tour some of the cartoon movies
they've made are incredible like I love
those like the the dark knight parts one
and two I can't remember what they were
I don't think I care what they were
called but on the older Bruce Wayne
versions the one where you have Carrie
Kelly as
as Robin were solid I mean those were
really really good movies cad what else
the shorter movies where you had like
black adam fighting Shazam like those
are really cool you know I mean there
there are some some really really cool
some really cool stories so hobo joe
says we're all nerds yes we were happily
nerds I never understood why people got
their kicks off lake but I'll say this
man if if the only way you can make
yourself happy is to make other people
miserable then your life really sucks
the way I know that is because the
people's lives didn't suck they'd be out
enjoying it instead of trying to make
other people's lives miserable let's see
Deathstroke vs The Punisher Deathstroke
any day of the week punisher is cool I
love Frank Castle I'm get me wrong I
love Frank Frank Castle my homeboy but
Deathstroke all the way I mean
Deathstroke has training he's fought
Batman on countless occasions sometimes
to a standstill sometimes over got the
upper hand now I mean Deathstroke is
solid Punisher doesn't stand a chance
I'm sorry about his luck but now he has
the stand a chance against Deathstroke
so all you DC fans who were like fingers
crossed I really really really hope it's
hope it's destro quill you're right it's
destro so a canary or black widow Oh
black widow I'm a minha yeah Black Widow
black Canary's got a super little scream
whatever blackwood it would get past
that real fast so Dragon Balls you for
life yes what kind of guitar do you have
that is a Gibson um tell me Rob do I
bleed will I lead tonight you know you
know I let's talk about that for a
second chat let's let's watchers my my
watchers you know let's let's Warner
Brothers man what the hell are you guys
thinking they're creating one of the
most anticipated films in the history of
Hollywood in a history of like Tommy
books in general Batman vs Superman
you know and and people are just like
you know I am I'm so psyched Batman vs
Superman they have the opportunity to
release a trailer that hypes the hell
out of this movie and what do they do
they give us some stupid scene where
Batman's like tell me Superman do you
bleed you will tonight how stupid is
that like how stupid is that like you
know what you know what they needed to
hype up that film here's exactly what
they needed to hype up that film all
right to get people excited all they had
to do was show like a news clip all
right or not even a news clip it would
just be like like okay I like beer with
me here imagine this all right so you
have a TV you have what looks like a
screen like when you win the when it
comes on all you see is like what looks
like footage or grainy stills or
something like that you know where
various things like you would see on
multiple monitors a Superman's fight you
know with General Zod from the man of
steel and what is Sal telling me ok um
anyway so you have some grainy stills
like some some iphone footage different
things like that you know that are
showing up in multiple segments like
multiple blocks on a monitor look you've
got you know three rows of three blocks
and people you know it's being watched
you hear keyboards typing in the
background you know and then here the
camera starts zooming out as a camera
zooms out like you see a guy like you
see the corner of a guy's head coming up
out of the corner and the camera zooms
out more and more and more and as the
camera zooms out you get this big huge
space and eventually you realize that
it's just Bruce Wayne sitting in his
batman suit with this mask off watching
the events unfold in in Metropolis with
the man of steel cut the black like that
I'd be so height I would be like oh my
god yes that's all you need that's all
you need and and Warner Brothers is just
like hey guys like let's have this what
this tells me is that one of others does
not know fans one of others has no idea
what what like people like like what
people enjoy like they don't you know
it's whatever others has no idea what's
going on like they're there they're just
like Oh Batman vs Superman let's just
make the movie it'll get a bunch of
money
we'll call it a day you know and yeah
they're one of others don't know what
the hell they're doing so um how do I
think batfleck will batfleck will do I
mean it alittle the movies gonna make
money it's Batman vs Superman you know
it's it's gonna make money I mean is
it's gonna you know no one's gonna
question if people are just gonna be
like yes you know money yes you know and
they're gonna dig it but yeah um let's
see hey Rob do you think who do you
think should be the villain and the
spider-man movie I'm not sure about that
you know I've been kind of debating that
I think it should be a villain that we
haven't seen before you know the lizard
has the lizards shown up we've had dr.
well yeah we've had Doctor Octopus we we
haven't had Mysterio you know we have
we've had venom the venom kind of sucked
in my opinion I'd like to see Connor a
carnage but the problem is you can't do
carnage without venom so or if you did
it'd be really really confusing to fans
you know you couldn't you couldn't cover
that huge of a history of spider-man in
the opening credits or within the first
half an hour or 45 minutes it have to be
like a full film and then jump into
carnage that being said you know I think
Mysterio would be a great villain to
appear in in spider-man the question
becomes with the with Mysterio seem too
hokey even for comic book film it
depends if we get the kind of Mysterio
that we saw an old man Logan where he do
12 rain into killing all the x-men
that's a Mysterio I would love to see in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe but you
know if we don't if we get just kind of
the goofy one like I'm just going to use
my powers to rob a bank you know then
that's that'll be done it'll be hokey
and people will be like that that looks
silly and they won't really dig it so um
who would win in a fight reverse reverse
Rob or the chat um and they should just
do the flashpoint animated movie scene a
scene for scene let's see God you guys
are hounding me look at my twitter look
at my twitter
look at my twitter okay why am I looking
at my Twitter you guys are hounding me
about looking at Twitter
what do I think
okay you just ask me questions less
questions in the chat like I'll try to
answer your questions in the chat so um
do I read value in our image comics not
really I'm not really in the india will
not really into enemy into indie comics
i'm ron burgundy but but um you know
i'll get into those eventually um i
would say that i want to get into the
walking dead and i want to see what the
walking dead has to offer um but i
imagine that that well I guess I'm
Damiano in the 1s offer i guess maybe
see what it has to offer my channel to
see how receptive people would be
because here's here's the kicker here's
the funny thing i can upload a vid about
the walking dead and there's a handful
of people who would be like oh yes the
morning dad amazing you know but if this
if it pales in comparison to all the
other videos that i have then because i
have a threshold on what i define to be
a successful video on my channel and if
it doesn't meet that threshold i just
won't do it again so um let's see let's
do I ever think file of L or Adam
warlock will be introduced and going
into the galaxy two I wouldn't mind
seeing file a bell um that version of
quasar wasn't bad i thought you know
wonder what window Vaughn was he was a
useless character there was no point in
having it I mean he had his own solo
series where they were boring like yeah
man I never got into him but um you know
I think that Adam warlock will probably
appear in guardians of the galaxy two
more we could expect on a Morlock more
so than we can expect file avella
because as far as i understand it i mean
we saw the quasar bands and the and
what's his name's room and his thing and
the collector we saw the the quantum
bands along this collection but you know
Adam wash cocoon broke open at the end
of guardians of the galaxy so I think
we'll see Adam warlock and and the rest
of in the end of Marvel Cinematic
Universe definitely so let's see dude
the lucky dad is one of the most popular
shows on TV yes it is it is I mean I'm
thinking about doing a video like you
know asking the question what happens to
the community because I think a lot of
people are curious about that i'll
probably do it once it gets closer to
when the show comes back on TV which i
think it comes back in october so you
know what we'll see what's up
we'll see what's going on but um do you
ever listen to music while reading
comics um sometimes i do sometimes I
don't it really kind of depends on on it
depends on a fan of L was a second
quasar there's more to it she related to
win over on and so on but yeah she's a
second if she's the most popular quasar
so um you know it depends on how I feel
and what mood on man and so on and so
forth you know sometimes I will
sometimes I won't you know it just kind
of varies so what Rob what do you think
of a spider verse story and one really a
big fan of spite of worse when it first
came out like you know I wasn't a huge
fan of your stuff is getting boring well
they like 80,000 people who watch it
disagree with you so I guess you're just
the one goofball so um let's see I think
that that um mm I don't know I totally
forgot what I was thinking about when I
was gonna say well let's let's scroll
back up let's scroll back up oh we went
too far we went too far some goofball
got me off my train of thought there's
just like banned him for the heck of it
just hand him for fun off with his head
um let's see uh oh well I'll come back
to a later um let's see yeah the Civil
War series was the best on the Internet
why do you exhibit why do you exist that
is why do people live what's the purpose
of life let me tell you if that was a
question they could be answered in a
book it would solve the mystery of why
people do the things they do it would it
would have fixed humanity overnight um
let's see your Lantern versus Iron Man
with lantern Buster armor well now we
got a block that guy too let's see do I
like new 52 comics okay so the first
question iron man versus the green
lantern with the lantern Buster armor um
now Green Lantern definitely just
because of the fact that you're talking
about even if you were to get past Hal
Jordan or Kyle ray
or something like that one you probably
would get past calibrator because he'd
be able to use his his abilities to I
guess is creativity to somehow get past
20 stark and to even if that somehow
happens you've got the whole Lantern
Corps not to mention all the red
lanterns and the Indigo's and the star
sapphires all I got a stuff from you got
you got all kind of Tony Stark wouldn't
stand a chance and as far as new 52 the
new 52 i think was respectable you know
it was yeah how much emergency awesome
all the time um i think new 52 was was
solid in the sense that it gave people a
place to start that's all I got into DC
was starting with new 52 and you know
because it was a good starting point you
know but uh but ya know I think that
that new 52 is really good if you want
to get into DC new 52 is not so good if
you just want to know what the best
stories are in DC Comics so anyway let's
see I have a doubt what happened to
Jubilee did Marvel kill her honestly I
don't even remember last I heard you
believe was like a psychic vampire or
something like that and I stopped asking
questions I mean I'd you know once she
lost her ability in truth I haven't
cared about Jubilees since I'd the 2000s
like the the early 2000s since like
90-something and don't matter to me what
happens to her so if you could create a
new Lantern Corps what color would you
choose oh god
hmm see all the major colors are taken I
mean yellows taken green second blue
indigo purple red black white green you
know blue I think I already said blue I
mean all those all those are taken um I
would create the gray Lantern Corps but
the grant Lantern Corps would be more
baby like a balance you know between the
Black Lantern Corps the white lantern
corps in the sense that they weigh the
odd they'd be like the Jedi Council you
know they would be like the Guardians
like they would they would say we're
going away the odds you know what would
happen if we intervene here and if we
did something you know they take time
you know the problem is the stories like
that are born so um let's see I mean
Brown like the the poopy the poopy
lanterns likely to shoot poop out of
there out of the Rings what having said
guys we're going to bring the stream to
an end because we're getting into a
weird place here besides I need to go
ahead and record we record Punisher the
last man on earth and I'll have that
video up tomorrow make sure you guys
check the description for the strange
and Studios which is a channel that I
chose as a channel that I would support
here on on comics and coffee this week
and keep in mind if you guys want to be
featured on comics and coffee as a
channel that gets a shout-out make sure
you guys post in the weekly pool net
subreddit where you can actually what is
it not subreddit the weekly pool net
self-promotion section where you can
post up your own content posts up your
own videos and it's free rein you guys
can pretty much do whatever you want in
there the for the most people keep track
of it like they police themselves so if
you spam too much or if you post too
much content or if you keep bumping your
own threads people will tell you to stop
and and we're fine with that until you
know we keep an eye on it I know Tiffany
Danielle keep an eye on em you've any of
Sal keep an eye on it as long as doesn't
get out of control then the people are
just kind of like you know it's it's all
good but make sure you guys post up
there if you guys want to want to see
your your content or have the chance of
having a conscience out out here in my
youtube channel so
with that being said yeah I will I won't
catch you guys later it was fun i love
doing these so so yeah we do do more
happy videos by the way we're going to
get away from the depressing stuff we're
gonna do have your videos again so we'll
catch you guys later peace